now i know that looks awful okay but
really
these are all just constants mainly
right it's just that y that single value
that i'm after
okay now i'm going to use this um
when i get the area of pqrs and i'm just
going to have one
variable in that equation okay so
keep that in mind maybe sort of put
something around it so that in all of
your lines of working it doesn't get
lost
now i'm going to get the area of pqrs
i'm going to move this out of the way
so i can have a second column
okay now pqrs just a rectangle right and
i said it had dimensions x
by y um x by y
i know what x is in terms of y right
there's my
there's my x okay so x y y will become
this
times 2 a on h of 1 minus y
over h it's worth learning if you like
from this equation here you could
eliminated
y instead and have this equation in
terms of x's it doesn't matter
you're going to end up with an
equivalent equation okay
now let's see here um after you
simplify this you're going to end up
with oops sorry
a on h squared outside of h
y minus y squared that's just
eliminating this fraction and
getting the y in there and you can see
it's a quadratic okay
don't forget this 2a on h squared looks
terrible but it's just a constant
i've got to keep reminding you of that
because when you get a question like
this
it's very intimidating you're like if
i've done it right have i done it wrong
it's all fine so far
okay now that i've got this area in
terms of one variable
as usual with maximum questions i
differentiate
okay so the derivative of that area
with respect to y because that's the
variable over here
okay is going to be equal to because
that's a constant out the
front like if it was number five and you
were differentiating this
you would ignore that five and just go
after this part right you just stick it
out the front
and then x minus x squared turns into
minus two x
yeah that's how you differentiate well
this is also a constant at the front
so just ignore it stick it there and
then forget that it's there
look at these parts which are the real
bits we're interested in differentiating
so the derivative of h y y is the
variable h
is the constant so this is h okay
minus 2 y is that okay
all right now to find our maximum area
right i'm going to use stationary point
here
well stationary points exist when that
derivative is zero
um
okay i'm just trying to be quick so that
i don't have to write this whole thing
and you can see there's only one
solution to this right this part out the
front the constant doesn't matter
so h minus 2y that part's got to be
equal to zero
right so you move your um 2y over you
get 2y is equal to h
y equals h on 2. now remember what we're
trying to prove
right we're after this area being half
that area so this is a very promising
sign
because it looks like our numbers are
headed in the right direction okay
there's a stationary point but to know
that it's a maximum
you've actually got to show that okay so
looking at this first derivative
do you think it would be easier to test
it's a maximum by first moving on either
side
or by using the second derivative
first or second derivative i think
second
because when you look at this even
though it looks awful all of these are
constants
so when i differentiate they're just
going to vanish it's actually just a
linear function
okay so if i differentiate again second
derivative
of this area function with respect to y
again okay this part is going to
disappear
i'm just going to end up with this which
is minus 2. 2 a
h squared minus 2. okay
so this is minus 4a on h squared now you
look at that and you're like
hold on at this point we're used to
finding a number of some kind
okay like minus 3 or 12 or something
like that this doesn't look like a
number
but it is because a is just the constant
and so is h
but you need to know why do we go what
result were we wanting out of
the second derivative we want concavity
right we hope that this is a max
okay so we're expecting this to be
concave
down right so expecting this to be
negative is it negative
yeah it is negative because
a is greater than zero right it's an
area and h
is greater than zero because it's a
length right therefore
this is negative okay now that's
crucially important to make that
okay um there's a classic question again
it's out of this exercise it's talking
about the strength
of a um a wooden log and it has to you
end up with when you differentiate
you get something like this and it's got
letters in it you can't just say oh it's
negative
because the question promised it would
be negative okay you gotta say why
that you've got a minus sign at the
front and these other bits are positive
okay so this is crucially important
therefore concave down
maximum okay now
the end points here are kind of trivial
because if you um
take y to its minimum it's going to be
zero so no area
if you take y to its maximum it'll be
equal to the vertical the perpendicular
height again
it'll be zero so this is the height that
i'm after this is the absolute max
now height is related to the area that
i'm interested in
okay so you bring it back to
your area function okay the area of
p q r s that rectangle okay
it works out to be here's my um let's
see here
here's my area function okay 2a on h
squared outside of
h squared on 2 minus
h squared on 4.
now check out you see where my
substitution has gone into here
okay and what you've got here 2a
on h squared times
uh let's see here h squared on
four right a half minus a quarter it's
just a quarter
h squared cancels two cancels leaving
you with a
two on the bottom and it's half the area
as we were hoping okay so
when someone holds your hand through it
you're like oh that's not so hard
what's difficult about this question
you've got to start off with all of
these unknowns and there are no numbers
to help you out okay
then you've got to find a relationship
so that you can eliminate one of these
you can only have one variable
so that you can differentiate okay the
rest of it i think you guys know how to
do
when we get like what in the example um
would you get walkthrough in the exam it
depends what section of the exam this
question
is okay so if it was the last section
right um question four part e or
whatever
um i think it would be you've got sort
of like a 50 50 chance
that they might guide you through say
showing this similarity
right and then go for it or they might
just dump you in the deep end
okay if it was say an earlier section
you know question two instead of
question four
they'll probably have a few more steps
there okay but they're expecting you the
later it comes in the exam
they're expecting you to work out more
of it on your own
does that make sense